>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> David Brown: Our speaker
this session is Harold Varmus.
It's hard to know how to describe
him although the first appositional
phrase would almost certainly be
1989 winner of the Nobel Prize
in medicine or physiology.
[ Applause ]
>> David Brown: As readers of Dr.
Varmus' autobiography of last year,
The Art and Politics of
Science know or barring that,
readers of last Sunday's Book
World section in the Post,
our speaker came to
science quite indirectly.
The son of a physician he
went to Amherst College
where he was an English major
who also took all of
a pre-med curriculum.
He opted to pursue English; went
to Harvard to get a Doctorate
but dropped out when he felt the
siren song of family expectation
and practical usefulness
draw him back to medicine.
He may have been one of the few
people who sat his parents down,
told them he was going to medical
school and saw their faces drop.
What happened to our
son the English prof?
He went to medical school but
he didn't go into medicine.
Instead he went into science which
is quite a different enterprise.
He learned to talk the language of
science late and perhaps came to wit
with the inside and daring
of a non-native speaker;
and he barged right into the
most heated conversation.
What is the relationship
between genes, the repository
of our permanent biological
identity and cancer,
the disease of wild
and fatal innovation?
He and Michael Bishop
found part of the answer
in onko [assumed spelling] genes.
They're the virus-like remnants
in our DNA heritage that can
under certain circumstances
be awakened
to produce uncontrolled cell growth.
The modern understanding
of cancer and someday much
of the therapeutics will
owe their debt to him.
Dr. Varmus went on to become the
head of the National Institutes
of Health during the Clinton
years and later the head
of the Memorial Sloan-Kettering
in New York.
He recently accepted
President Obama's invitation
to become the Director of the
National Cancer Institute,
which I guess is a little bit
like William Howard Taft
becoming Chief Justice
after becoming President.
He's also a big bicyclist.
One day on vacation in France he got
up before breakfast to go for a ride
and ended up in another
country-- Italy I believe.
Please welcome Harold Varmus.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Varmus: Well I want to begin
with a couple of thanks not just
to the Library of Congress
and the Washington Post
which have been thanked many, many
times but I want to thank Michelle
for bringing my message to those
of you who have hearing problems,
and I want to thank my friend
David Brown, himself a physician
and distinguished science reporter,
for his very depth introduction.
I also want to thank all of you.
I've been sitting around listening
to people all day and I'm about worn
out so your endurance is great
so thank you very much for those
of are back loaded on
the program for you
to have stayed around for us.
Now unlike most of the other
speakers you've heard from today,
I don't call myself an author
except possibly on days like today;
and I am now above
all else a scientist.
When I'm asked at integration what
do I do I don't way I write books;
I say I do science or I'm
a government official.
I'm also lapse position and
I run some institutions;
but for like most academically
based scientists I've done a lot
of writing, usually in my own fields
of cancer research
and virus research.
But like many other
speakers you've heard from,
I aspire to be an author.
And last year to give
myself legitimacy
in this role I did publish
a book, as you've heard,
about my life in science
and politics.
How did that happen?
Well in 2003 a friend of mine,
the noted barber for Gene Strauss
who runs the program
in the Humanities
at the New York Public Library,
asked me to give a series
of lectures called the Norton
Lectures to talk to humanists
about science; initially
she wanted me to talk
about C.P. Snow's 'Two Cultures';
that idea seemed a little worn out
and I put together three lectures on
becoming a scientists, doing science
and being a scientist
engaged in politics.
I gave the lectures, that was fun in
2004 and then I read the contract.
And the contract said that after the
lectures were given a book would be
delivered to Norton after
which a check will be received.
So that you might think
would be a strong motivation
but indeed it took me four
more years to write the book
because unlike one
might have anticipated
from one's initial reaction
to a contract like that,
you can't simply take three
lectures and put them into a book.
Books take a lot more work and a lot
more depth, and indeed after a lot
of procrastination I tried to
give it that kind of depth.
Now, a motivation to
put the lectures
into a book form was not
simply based on the idea
of getting a modest check from
the Norton Publishing Company.
Indeed as I thought about it, I
realized that the country needed--
at least those who might
be readers of this book,
could profit from a better
explanation of what human motivation
and trials and tribulations lie
behind the science that people read
about when David Brown
and others report on it.
I was also concerned
that despite the fact
that this is the age of Obama.
I stood here on Inauguration Day and
heard the new President declare it
in his Inaugural Address that
he was going to restore science
to its rightful place, that science
was one of the few ways we had
to deal with the chronic and acute
problems of our society, disease
and environmental degradation, lack
of energy sources and difficulties
in our economy; and I believe
I that and yet I am concerned
that for most people science remains
an abstraction not a human activity.
And in particular, not a human
activity with moments of drama,
frustration, exhilaration
and as a result for people
who don't understand this, science
and scientists are mysterious
and remote; not an exciting realm of
activity carried out by real people.
This notion very nicely expressed
by my new friend Richard Holmes,
the British author who is speaking
in a tent a few blocks away hence
my sweaty appearance in front
of you a few minutes a go, who
in his book, the Age of Wonder,
a book about science and
the arts in the late 18th
and early 19th Century
said as a means
of explaining why he wrote the
book he wrote, it's now important
to understand how science
is actually made;
how scientists themselves think
and feel and speculate and we need
to explore what makes scientists
creative as well as poets
or painters of musicians.
So, there are a lot of
ways to tackle this problem
and indeed there are now movies.
There's even a recent opera, John
Adams' Dr. Atomic, there are books
like Richard Holmes that
describe histories of science--
how the atomic bomb was made and you
just heard that from Richard Rhodes;
the Eighth Day of Creation and
others that I won't bore you with.
There are biographies; that is,
books written by authors
about famous scientists.
The one I like particularly
is the book by Lisa Jardine
on the Curious Life of Robert Hook,
a 17th Century scientist,
one of the first.
There are novelistic treatments
of science that are entertaining
and often give a picture
of what science is like;
one of our speakers
today Allegra Goodman,
has written a very wonderful
book called Intuition
about doing the kind of
science my lab does; Ian McEwen,
the remarkable novelist has written
a recent book about a physicist,
a book entitled Solar;
and again C.P. Snow,
who I mentioned earlier has written
several good books including The
Search and The Masters.
And there's poetry-- poetry by
a woman named Rebecca Ellison,
an astronomer, called A
Responsibility to Awe.
My own book, as you've heard, is
in the realm of memoir and here I'm
in a realm in which
there are giants.
The biggest giant in this
field is Jim Watson whose book,
The Double Helix, broke the ice
and having scientists talk
about the work they do.
My own emphasis has been
focused on three broad topics;
each of which represents an
important aspect of science,
and each of which reflects the
odd features of my own career.
So first how do you
become a scientist?
And as you've heard
briefly from David,
I had a tortuous path
toward science,
a path that illustrates the
forgiving nature of American society
that allows one to have a prolonged
adolescence and win one's way
through literature and medicine
and eventually on to science.
My family background is
interesting in the sense
that my grandparents escaped
anti-Semitism and poverty in Europe,
came to this country around the
turn of-- last turn of the century,
and yet in only the course of a
few years had children who went
to ivy league colleges,
had professional success,
and gave me the luxury of being able
to indulge my curiosity
about many fields.
Then the Vietnam War played
a role in my transitions
because as a physician trained
in the 60's, I was obligated
to serve my country which was then
fighting a war that I didn't approve
of and I became a member of a core
often called the Yellow Berets,
young doctors who often were
objectors to the war who ended
up in a wonderful situation being
trained at the National Institutes
of Health which has been the fuel
of my loyalty to that institution
over the last forty years.
At the NIH I learned what science
could do and how engaging it was,
and part of that experience is
what fuels my current enthusiasm
for telling others how
wonderful science can be.
So that's one part of the story.
The second part has to do with the
science itself and here as a writer
who understands a lot of molecular
biology, I knew I had a challenge.
I had been trying to teach my wife
for 41 years what I do in the lab
and I can tell you it's
not easy to do that.
So I've tried to figure out
how I could distill the kind
of science I work on into
a story that could connect
with some basic facts
that people know
like The Double Helix is the shape
of DNA; and to try to explain how--
curiosity about how a
virus that caused cancer
in chickens could be pursued to
understand the fundamental nature
of cancer in human beings.
And I try to take the reader
through a series of steps
that reflect both the
struggles of doing the work
and the current triumphalism that
some of us feel about the new kinds
of therapies and strategies
for prevention and diagnosis,
that are the result of that work.
Along the way the work was of course
it carried out not just by me alone
but a partner, Michael Bishop,
with whom I shared the Nobel Prize
several years ago, and by a number
of trainees all of whom
I tried to portray--
some of whom I tried
to portray in the book.
Finally, I wanted to
talk about something
that was an unusual
experience for scientists
like myself namely a change into
a kind of politician of science.
The prize having given me a
certain unearned creditability
as a spokesperson, I was turned to
for opinions and eventually asked
to run the nation's, indeed
the world's largest supporter
by medical research, the NIH.
And in that role I had to learn
a lot about budgets and politics
that I didn't know before, and
set scientific priorities and deal
with advocacy groups and many
other supporters and critics.
So that whole realm of activity
is one that I think is useful
for other scientists to
know about and for those
who respect science to understand.
Along the way as I took on the
chores of being the director of NIH,
I was privileged to deal with
a number of important issues
that have become obsessions
for me in the ensuing years--
in the 10 years since I've
been at the NIH as director.
One if the importance of research
on stem cells, another is the means
in which we use the Internet
to promulgate our work
and make it more accessible
to others,
and the third is the importance
of using the information we know
about research and medicine to
try to improve the status of most
of the world living in lower
middle income and poor countries
in a field called Global
Health and Global Science.
Now I am in a tent called
contemporary and I want
to remind you that some of these
issues are just as alive today
as they were ten years ago;
indeed the World Cancer Research
of course is moving ahead
extremely rapidly these days.
Three of the big issues that I've
mentioned are still in the news.
Open access publication is now
something which is widely respected
and carried out without
financial disaster;
and congress has directed
the NIH to insure that all
of the work that's carried
out with this money ends
up in a publically accessible
database within a year.
Second...
[ Applause ]
Dr. Varmus: Thank you.
Secondly, the nation is
taking seriously the challenge
of improving health in
developing countries
and the Obama Administration's
global health initiative is setting
a new standard extending some
very commendable wok carried
out by the Bush Administration
in providing remedies for HIV
under the Cupfar [assumed spelling]
Program; and as I'm sure many
of you know stem cell research is,
while having advanced dramatically
over the last several years
and having been encouraged
by the Obama Administration,
has taken a real blow
with a recent ruling that has
offered a reinterpretation
of an appropriate provision
that now threatens the future
of stem cell research.
As you've heard I am back at the NIH
as director of the Cancer Institute,
and the adventure is ongoing
and with luck maybe
there'll be another book.
Well thanks very much and
happy to take some questions.
[ Applause ]
>> Audience question: Coleridge,
the poet, had a dream that lead
to his poem, Kubla Khan and as you
know Keloy [assumed spelling] had
the dream about the Benzene
ring; and I was wondering...
>> Dr. Varmus: That's the
snake devouring its own tail.
>> Audience question:
And I was wondering
about the creative process.
Is there such a thing that has
inspiration in science and if
so is it analogist to
that and what are...?
>> Dr. Varmus: Yes and so I'm not
an authority on the creative process
but one of the things I
try to do in this book is
to relate how ideas came to me.
I don't really understand how it
happens but one important idea
that happens to lie in the narrative
of the work I did is somebody
trying to find cancer genes.
Just popped into my head when I
was wheeling my six-month old son
through a churchyard during
a sabbatical in London.
And I would say the important
thing there is the word sabbatical.
Many of my fellow scientists
don't take a year off;
they just plunge ahead all the time.
They're working, working, working,
trying to get their next
graph [assumed spelling],
publish the next paper and I
think some time to get away
from routine work and
think more deeply
about science is an important thing.
I'm in the midst of trying
to do an analogist thing
at the NIH at the moment.
We're in a phase of
remarkably dense data generation
in the cancer research world; and
I've asked a number of my colleagues
to come together and think not
about the next piece of data
or how we interpret it
but what are the big ideas
that we have not been working on
that we now could possibly answer.
Hopefully out of that
process of saying
to my colleagues I know
there are a lot of ideas
that we really haven't
thought much about.
For example, we all say isn't
it amazing Lance Armstrong was--
took chemotherapy for
testicular cancer
and then won seven tours of France.
But we don't think
much on a daily basis
about why cyst platen actually
cures testicular cancer,
and I find myself saying
all the time
if we could make cancer a
controllable chronic disease,
that would be a real step
forward and it would be.
But I don't think we
should lose site of the fact
that in some situations and there
are a few other diseases as well,
chemotherapy does cure cancer.
Why does that happen?
It's a tough problem to answer
but I think we have tools
to try to look at that now.
Sorry. Over here; I'm
going to alternate.
>> Audience question: My question
is about stem cell research.
And given that it's an ethical
controversy isn't it true
that we can make any
cell pluripotent--
we have enough information
to do that.
Can we now go about it another way?
Why not, if not, is it not a form
of slavery if you can own a life
like that and do whatever
you want with it otherwise?
>> Dr. Varmus: Let me try
to answer that question.
You're referring of
course to the induction
of what are called
pluripotent stem cells--
a very important method that may
actually be the most important
technology in developing
therapeutic cells.
But I would caution you a little bit
about that because we've only known
about induced pluripotent
stem cells for a few years.
We know already that they are not
identical to embryonic stem cells.
There are limitations in
their potential very likely,
they retain memory of the
kind of mature cell they were;
it probably weighs around that but
if you want to compare those cells
with the most well
understood primitive cell
with maximum potential I think it is
important to carry out comparisons
with human embryonic stem cells.
Now, I think your other point about
enslaving a life depends a lot
on what one considers life; and here
we have an area of moral argument.
But I would point out what most
scientists are saying at this point
about the process by which stem
cell research is being funded is
that what they're asking
is that cells derived
with non-federal money be
used or be able to be used
with federal money to
do further studies.
So there is a division that
was made traditionally accepted
by the Bush Administration and
by the Clinton Administration too
but also the Obama Administration
to allow work on stem cells
that have been derived with
non-public money; non-federal money.
That's an arguable position.
I know there are people who feel
strongly the other way but I think
that the benefits to human life of
working with cells that were derived
from smaller cluster of cells that
were going to be discarded anyway,
makes a lot of sense to me.
[ Applause ]
>> Audience question: Would you
say a few words about copyright
and the way you can
do things over the web
and perhaps even micro
dollar exchanges
or something of that nature?
>> Dr. Varmus: Sure I
assume you mean the context
of scientific publication.
Now I'm not anti-copyright
by any means.
I believe the copyright is useful,
but traditionally what
authors have done
because there really
was no alternative,
was to turn over copyright
to publishers
after their papers were
accepted and allow publishers
to do whatever they
like with papers.
I think there's another way
to do things and that is
to allow the copyright
to be held by authors.
We're in, of course
a realm this day,
of authors who make their living by
selling their work and I don't want
to stop doing that; that's
very, very, important.
But most of us who are scientists
when we write scientific articles
we're not interested in money;
we're interested in fame.
We don't get money for
the publications we write.
What we want to do we want
everybody to read our papers,
we want those papers to be not just
famous by read by others and built
on because the scientific process
depends on the dissemination
of one's work and the greatest
possible access by other scientists.
So in the world of open access
publication what's done is
to allow the author to hold
the copyright and not turn it
over to the Journal, and
grant a license to the Journal
to publish the work, allow it to be
used freely for any purpose as long
as acknowledgment of
authorship is retained.
I think that's a very
reasonable position;
it's one that's been
espoused by many journals
and in the larger world it's
become routine now at least
in the biomedical world, even
if one doesn't publish an open
access journal but in journals
that are either for-profit
or for the sustenance
of scientific societies to
allow that work to be placed
in a public repository called
Pub Med Central how to the NIH;
and that has served the scientific
community exceedingly well.
I believe the delay
of a year is excessive
but the copyright rules
there have been worked out
and we've made a big
improvement in the way
in which we all access
scientific literature.
Libraries have become smaller,
of course there's a crisis
in university libraries
created by the pricing practices
of many for-profit journals; and one
of the few ways to try to overcome
that is by publishing by a
different business method,
the open access method
which we know works.
The open access publishing house
that I founded some years ago
with my colleagues called the Public
Library of Science, now actually is
in the black and doing experiments
with the excessive income
that it receives from the
publication fee paid by the authors;
and everything that's published
by the group is made instantly
available to the entire world
for free at the time of publication.
Over here?
>> Audience question: Because of my
personal and family history I feel
that going to the doctor is very
important, having the colonoscopy
and in my case being tested for skin
problems because I've had melanoma.
Harold, how much is detection in
education for preventive medicine?
How important is that for the NIH
and what is your priority
with that-- with NIH?
>> Dr. Varmus: Well, I think
this is extremely important
and indeed we know that
prevention is often not as sexy.
I'm not often asked when are
you going to prevent cancer;
I'm asked when are you
going to cure cancer?
Because there are no grateful
people who's cancers were prevented.
So screening is incredibly important
and we need to do a better job
but that's not just the job of the
NIH of course, but it's the job
of personal physicians,
it's the job of the CDC,
it's the job of the
Department and Health
and Human Services more generally;
I'd like to think it's the job
of the insurance companies which
have a great deal to benefit
from preventing disease
becomes very costly.
So this is a major thrust in my
own administration at the NCI.
I think we can do a lot in
prevention both here at home
and also around the world.
We tend to neglect cancer as
a threat to poor populations;
but the fact is that cancer is
a major burden of disease even
in the poorest countries, and there
are many things that could be done--
whether it's vaccination
against Hepatitis B
or Papillomavirus infection, or
whether it's reduction in use
of tobacco or early detection of
other cancers, simple surgeries,
use of those anti-cancer
drugs who have gone off patent
and become feasible for
use in poor countries.
So from my point of view emphasizing
prevention and dissemination
of what can be done, using
the Internet to help us
out in dissemination is
a very important feature
of what we see happening in
the next five to ten years.
Over here?
>> Audience question: Okay I guess
my question is I worked in the lab
for a while so I understand
that there is some good science
and some bad science and so...
>> Dr. Varmus: What do
you mean by bad science?
>> Audience question: Some science
that doesn't follow protocol perhaps
as closely as others do; and so
the results may be somewhat skewed
and so I see the benefit in having
peer review before publication.
>> Dr. Varmus: Nothing I've said
about open access publication has
anything to do with peer review.
Open access publication
is all peer review.
>> Audience question: Oh okay.
But I think that the change
in funding structure during
the Reagan era had some effect
on willingness to share data, and I
wondered if there had been any sort
of study that has looked
at how that change
in funding structure
has had an effect.
>> Dr. Varmus: Actually
I'm not sure what change
in funding structure you're
talking about but I would say
that on the whole the
willingness of scientists
to share data has increased
enormously; and it's increased
in part because of the
kind of science we're doing
which is much more data intensive,
it requires teams much more often;
a phenomena which I
think has its own dangers
because sometimes the greatest
moments in science occur
when a lone scientists is
thinking alone about a problem
and not working in a team;
but nevertheless there is
much more team science,
much more interaction
among scientists
of different institutions,
and the nature
of the science itself
demands more sharing.
In addition to that voluntary
willingness to do more as teams,
the NCI and other institutes of the
NIH demand sharing policies as part
of grant applications
and I think that we're
on a good trajectory in that regard.
>> Audience question:
Can you talk a little bit
about the funding decisions.
How it's decided which programs
get funded and related to that
about publicizing what the NIH does
so you can build support
within the community.
>> Dr. Varmus: Right well
on your latter topic,
I think we have pretty good support
from the American community for NIH
and what it does, but it
could be a lot more informed
and we are responsible
for creating stories
that reflect what we're doing,
explain to the public more fully.
And I think the instinct
is to support the NIH
because life expectancy in
this country has improved,
we're the pioneers in the world
and generating sophisticated
new approaches to healthcare.
And I think the reputation
of the NIH is strong
but I do agree with you.
In fact I was meeting with
some journalists today to talk
about how the NCI should
sort of redraft its story
so we're not worried day by day
about whether we're winning the war
in cancer, but instead talking
about what has actually happened,
how our understanding of why a
normal cell becomes a cancer cell
can be translated into
new ways to prevent
and treat and diagnose cancer.
So I agree with those points.
Your first point was?
>> Audience question: About
the funding decision--
how do you decide what
programs get funded?
>> Dr. Varmus: First of all
there's a macro set of decisions.
How much does the President ask
Congress to give to the NIH?
How does Congress decide how much
it's going to give to the NIH
and those are issues
that we participate
in by telling the President
and Congress what we
could do with more money?
In general, Congress and the
Presidents have been kind
to the NIH; we're probably
among the agencies least likely
to have our budget cut at
a time of verconian cuts
that are talked about
by both parties.
And but you're asking
about is how do we
at the Cancer Institute
decide which programs to fund.
And that's a complicated process.
Some of its determined simply
by peer review we're saying
that grants better than that grant.
Some of its decided by saying you
know we looked at our portfolio,
we're not doing anything on cancer
X and there's a new opportunity.
So you've got to weigh
the burden of the disease,
the public health effects
of the disease
against first the opportunities
to study that disease specifically
and importantly against the
opportunities to make end roads
against a certain disease
by studying something
that may not be obvious
to the public.
The public says well
ovarian cancer is terrible,
let's invest in ovarian cancer.
But it may be that
understanding something
about DNA is repaired
may be more important
and I'm using new facts here to
inform that specific suggestion.
Someone's holding in the front row
a sign that says to me overtime.
This is not a football match; you
should not be more excited by that.
We have to acknowledge that we're
reached the end of the hour;
other speakers are
lined up behind me.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.